Assalamu Alaikum, Muhammad
Allah would better care. I'm outside Kabul Corner.
I'm about to try the best Afghani burgers in London, apparently.
And let's see if this place is any decent.
Or should we say Paka?
So I travel three hours to get to this establishment
and I tell you what, it was like winter wonderland.
Look at this little setup.
Moving over to the burger,
we got chicken tenders, we got salami,
we got sausages with some chips,
garnish with this sauce wrapped up.
And here we go, about to Munch.
Also recommended to try some of their soup.
I've tried the most famous Afghani burger in London. Burger.
It's a wrap. Bismillah.
Not even gonna lie to you,
the burger was incredibly dry.
This is how Afghanis like it.
Comment down below chat to tell me if this is true.
For me and the wrap, we had eye to eye contact
and we said we have to dip it in the gravy sauce
even though it was a chicken soup.
And to be honest, the combination was fantastic.
The fries on the other hand was incredibly nice.
10 out of 10. Cause they put a lot of vinegar in the soup.
It was a bit too overwhelming in my opinion.
However, I.
Oh, this is bagging, bro.
I go pay them a visit there in Harrow Wilson.